allez ouais si vers le way se levait
tenir droit debout sur ses jambes voilà
des gestes des efforts devenu possible
pour nathan après des mois et des années
d'apprentissage
né en novembre 2007 nathan est un bébé
alors comme tous les autres il pleure
jouer passe du temps dans les bras de
ses parents
les choses se compliquent en octobre
2008 nathan devient alors sujets à des
vomissements des tremblements anormaux
et a commencé à être dans les vapes
on la change les comportements il
bougeait plus trop et gueye fixer des
choses on sait pas quoi mais fixer les
choses
il a commencé à vomir donc on avait
pensé à une gastro enfin voilà cette
période où on si c'est pas grave c'est
surtout quand il a commencé à se mettre
à trembler köhler a trouvé ça bizarre
s'ensuit alors un long combat pour
nathan et sa famille combat contre des
médecins qui ne mesurent pas l'ampleur
de la maladie mais aussi pour trouver un
traitement efficace
la situation de nathan ne s'améliore
réellement qu'en 2010 avec la mise en
place d'un nouveau programme anti
épileptiques un élan de solidarité à
création une association permettent eux
de financer des thérapies à l'étranger
en espagne
nathan réapprend à tenir debout à se
concentrer sa vie s'améliore problème
les stages coûte cher plusieurs milliers
d'euros pour trois semaines en 2016 on a
réussi à faire de ce stage en espagne
deux semaines et trois semaines sachant
que trois semaines de stage c'est 5000
euros donc on a fait également un stage
d'une semaine au centre brain move à
saint malo on a testé on a financé des
orthèses on a financé une poussette
enfin il n'y a pas que la thérapie en
soit il ya aussi tous les à côtés tout
ce qui est médicale pour l'aider au
maximum la soirée inattendue organisé le
samedi 21 janvier à cerner la ville
permettra de financer une partie des
stages prévus cette année
elle permettra également de continuer le
combat de nathan